لا بالعمليه العسكريه تركيه شمال سوريا
والعراق حيث افادت مصادر ومحليه لجزيره
بان قصف تركيا ازده نقاطا لما تعرفوا
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في محيطها راس
العين العرب كوباني وغرب تمر وريف زركان
في الحسكه
تحالف الدوليه الى القيام بمسؤولياته اكثر
حيا لما يجري في المنطقه
احمد القوات الضامنه شمال وشرق سوريا
بالضعيفه وقالت الى تلك القوات لم تبدي
حتى الان اي مواقف جديه
انه تم ابلاغ الجانب الروسي بعدم قبول
تركيا لانتشار الشكليه لقوات النظام
السوري في مناطق ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه
على ضروره حل ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه او اخراجها من مناطق النفوذ
الروسيات عسكريه واللوجسيه اللازمه لتنفيذ
العمليه العسكريه الشماليه سوريا قال ان
العمليه لن تهدد القوات الامريكيه
والروسيه
للجزيره ان هدف المرحله الاولى من العمليه
العسكريه والسيطره على تل رفعت ومنبج وعين
العرب مشيرا لان الجانب الامريكي ابدى
تفاهمه للمطالب بالتركيه وان المعلومات
المتوفره لدى الجانب التركي تشير الى اننا
انسحبوا من بعض المواقع
وقلت وسائل الاعلام التركيه عن الامن
التركيه قوله انه حدد فاطمه او نور مسؤوله
المخابرات في حزب العمال الكردستاني وذلك
في عمليه للمخابرات التركيه في جبل سنجر
من شمالي العراق
من اجازه في حلب الجزيره ادهم ابو الحسن
كما ينضم الينا من على الحدود التركيه
السوريه مراسله الجزيره عمر الحاج واخر
التطورات ادهم
نعم عبد الصمد منذ قليل القواعد التركيه
المتواجده في ريف حلب الشمالي استهدفت
مواقع لما تعرف قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في
كل من
برج القوس ومياسه وايضا قريه تم قريه تم
هذه القريه التي تقع في جنوب شرق مدينه
عفرين وهي همم يعني تتضمن بداخلها نقاط
مشتركه لقوات النظام وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه لكن نستطيع ان نقول عبد الصمد انه
خلال 48 ساعه الماضيه هذه الساعات تعتبر
الاكثر هدوءا منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه
التركيه هذا الهدوء ربما يعزا الى المهله
التركيه التي اعطت الحي المفاوضات من قبل
الجانب الروسي مع ما تعرض قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه والتي اا تتفاوض تتفاوض بها
الجانب الروسي همم ربما يستطيع اقناع همم
ما تعرض لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه الانسحاب
من المناطق التي ربما تستهدفها العمليه
العسكريه في كل منبج ومنطقه الرفعه وعين
العرب
قابل عبد الصمد مصادر محليه للجزيره قالت
انما تعرض قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تستغل
هذه المهله برفع السواتر الاضافيه وزياده
التحصينات اضافه الى عمليات التخفي
والتمويه ومناشدات تصل من همم عده مناطق
سواء في مخيمات سد الشهباء همم الخاض الذي
سيطرت مع تعرض بالقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
او منبج او مدينه منبج مناشدات من
المدنيين بان وحدات حمايه الشعوب الكرديه
لا تسمح للمدنيين بالخروج خارج هذه المدن
والقرى التي تسيطر عليها ايضا على صعيد
اخر النظام السوري يدفع بمزيد من
التعزيزات لقوات قتاليه عبد الصمد تابعه
للفرقه 25 التي يقودها سهيل الحسن المقرب
من روسيا اضافه ثاني الى الحرس الجمهوري
والفرقه الرابعه
بشكل مباشر هذا اندل فانه يدل على انه
ربما يكون هناك في الايام المقبله ان بدات
المعارك ولم تتسجب وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه الانسحاب من هذه المناطق ربما
تشارك القوات السوريه قوات النظام السوري
الى جانب وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه في
المعركه حتى الان همم ساعات من الهدوء
تسود المنطقه همم فصائل المعارضه الفيارق
الثلاثه التابعه للجيش الوطني ما زالت
مستنفره وعلى اوبت الاستعداد لكن الهدوء
هو سيد الموقف رئيس ما تنتهي المولى التي
لا نعرف موعد انتهاء بالضبط بالضبط
وما هي خياراته تعامله مع دخول القوات
السوريه المحتمله على خط المواجهه
نعم مريم تركيا في كل تصريحاتها تقول انها
عازمه على تنفيذ هذه العمليه العسكريه في
حال لم تنصح هذه القوات وهذه الوحدات
للشروط التي تقدمت بها تركيا عبر الوساده
الروسيه والحقيقه ان تركيا تترجم هذه
الاقوال الى افعال على الارض بينما تعطي
مهله لهذه الوحدات تستمر وان كان بوتيره
اقل من الايام السابقه باستهداف مواقعها
سواء في سوريا وحتى في شمال العراق لان
هذه العمليه العسكريه جزء من عمليه تشنوا
منذ عام 2019 في كلا البلدين ضد من تسميهم
تركيا
بالعناصر الارهابيه بالنسبه للشرق الثاني
من السؤال تركيا قالت انها همم
ليس لديها اي مشكله في ان تحل قوات النظام
وايضا همم اجهزته الامنيه ومؤسساته
الرسميه اضافه الى حرس الحدود في هذه
المناطق ولكنها قالت في الحديث الاخير ل
همم
جزيره من مصدر رسمي تركي خالي للجزيره ان
تركيا لن تقبل بذلك الانتشار الصوري او
انتشار الشكلي الذي جرى في عام 2019 حين
رفعت الاعلام السوريه ولكن لم يكن هناك اي
وجود للقوات السوريه كما ان هذه القوات ما
تسمى بوحدات حمايه الشعب ما زالت موجوده
في تلك المناطق تركيا تريد الان تطبيقا
فعليا لهذا الامر وايضا مريم لابد من
تذكير ببعض التصريحات التركيه خاصه من
الرئيس اردوان الذي قال ان ا ا تقاربا
مشابها بين تركيا بينما حدث بين مصر
وتركيا قد يحدث في الايام المقبله بين
النظام السوري و بين تركيا وفي هذا ربما
كانت تمهيد لقبول لتركيا بوجوده النظام
السوري على حدودها بعد اكثر من احد عشر
عاما من اندلاع الثوره السوريه اذن تركيا
بهذه الوساطه كانت قبلت بهذا الشوط ولا
انا حتى الان ان كانت روسيا من فرض هذا
الشرط لتقبل بالوساطه ولكن ما نعلم حتى
الان الانسحاب على الارض تم من قبل هذه
القوات اعلام هذه الوحدات سواء المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها في منبج وايضا ترفعت
كذلك في عين العرب ذات الاهميه الرمزيه
لها ما تزال موجودات تركيا في تصريحاتها
الاخيره تبدو الان اكثر جاهزيه تبدي
جاهزيه اكثر لتنفيذ هذه العمليه اذ بان
الحديث يوم امس وايضا حديث ابراهيم قال
مستشار الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قال
ان تركيا قادره للتنفيذ عمليه سواء خلال
ايام الاسبوع القادم ولكنها تنفذ فقط ان
همم رات ان الظروف مناسبه وان هذه الوحدات
لن تنسى مره اخرى للوساطه الروسيه
على الحدود التركيه السوريه شكرا ايضا
لادهم ابو الحسين كان معنا من اعزاز سيري
في حلب